ce qui retient véritablement la tension
ce qui surprend au venezuela c'est que
le pays est complètement plongé dans la
noirceur depuis hier olivier même les a
pas d'école a aujourd'hui ça a été
annulé
les écolos ont été annulés mais on parle
aussi du métro la ville
je n'ai voulu vélos complets comme
caracas très très grosse ville derrière
qui était plongée dans le noir
vous le voyez d'ailleurs dernièrement
plusieurs belles photos cela dit alors
savoir d'amérique du sud vous voulez
vous voyez le venezuela dans la partie
nord d'amérique du sud avec la capitale
caracas complètement dans la loi mais on
parle de 21 des 23 états du venezuela
qui ont été plongés dans le noir en
raison d'une centrale donc eu un bris
dans une centrale qui fournit
l'électricité
ça donne des images qui sont absolument
magnifiques regardez si je pense on la
voit bien donc dans les quartiers très
poétique
le python vous le voyez c'est également
à l'intérieur des villes de carême des
rues de caracas est également celle ci
regardez s'est accélérée qu'on a trouvé
avec les moralisateurs les eaux alors on
voit très bien donc de plus en plus
d'obscurité dans la ville de caracas le
gros problème également falls est ce une
des villes qui les plus dangereuses du
monde
alors imagine tous les problèmes de
sécurité que ces années souvent
d'ailleurs on dit caracas et la ville
depuis dangereusement alors ça venait
défis logistiques
en attendant vous savez que le schéma du
rau toutes sortes de problèmes avec
l'opposition mais ce bois est doux si
les états unis alors monsieur maduro sur
twitter et yahia dit on pratique une
autre espagnole ensemble aguera electric
cars est dirigée par l'impérialisme
américain ligue 1 et les 3 et 10 qu'une
guerre électrique
à l'heure actuelle que sont les états
unis qui ont fait du sabotage la loge
centrale et c'est ce qui a amené donc ce
bris ce bruit d'électricité
wang wei dos parce qu'on vient dans le
trio virale vous allez voir winglois et
d'eau qui est la position donc et qui
est appuyée vous savez également par les
états unis à utiliser également twitter
dit il et aux arts il ya 22 états qui
sont sans lumière il a accusé nicolas
maduro président de négligence dans
toute cette affaire et le regarder le
troisième du triumvirat my pop et 11 en
ml
également secrétaire d'état a dit y'a
pas nourriture n'est pas de médicaments
pas d'électricité et maintenant on
n'espère pas de maduro lors des
prochains mois alors vous voyez donc
cette guerre d'électricité qu'on a pu
voir au venezuela
bon très bien merci